are you posting to just say happy Friday
or are you actually putting out content
to build brand the punch line are you
good at Twitter are you good at
Instagram are you good at Tick Tock and
certain humans are better at certain
platforms but the biggest brands in the
world over the next decade will be built
on the people that can execute best on
all of the platforms so they're hitting
as many customers as possible I would
say it's where your strategic creative
lands meaning Believe It or Not LinkedIn
for some consumer products is over
performing Twitter or Instagram for
certain brands because they understand
how to make the videos or pictures or
written words that hit that audience
better we call it socks strategic
organic content